let's take a live look together near
prim 15
southbound is on the right side of your
television moving away from las vegas
and heading towards southern california
apparently the backup earlier up to 20
miles in length
still tapping the brake pedal and stop
and go at this time 8 news dial reporter
sally jeremy live outside gene with more
on how the day looked and reaction from
visitors
brian many tourists tell me coming here
to las vegas to celebrate the fourth of
july was definitely worth it they
enjoyed
all the fun and especially the fireworks
but right now you can see the ride home
won't be easy
some say they plan to do it again next
year
we went to downtown and
we saw the fireworks there's a lot of
people
it's the pandemic we need to to at least
have a good time right
emily alba and her son isaac are
visiting from california they made the
decision to celebrate the fourth in las
vegas just last week
everything is partying in vegas it's
like you're free
from everything that's happening you
know this
is the place to be very fun you know
it's it's an american holiday it's the
most american holiday you can get
and the fireworks on the strip an added
bonus
i think they did too much of a good job
the worst part about the trip they say
now having to drive back home
we're feeling tired and hot pretty much
it's still a standstill but i wish it
could go faster
i do want to go home despite the
frustration from the stop and go
lasting memories were made as much as
there's traffic and stuff
it's still worth it uh you know you have
fun with your family it's a once in a
it's once in a year the journey was
worth it actually so you could come see
the fireworks
all day long people were stopping in
this area for water and snacks and
nevada highway patrol was in full force
they say they've been seeing a lot of
reckless driving
and of course they say eventually that
traffic will slow
down after that sun goes down that is 9
p.m
they recommend if you can stay for
another day reporting live here in jean
sally jaramillo 8 news now